Reisen schneller als das licht wir kennen das aus science fiction filmen wie star trek und so weiter
Eigentlich haben wir ja alle in der schule gelernt dass nicht
schneller sein kann als deutlich dennoch sind forschungs siemens weltweit dabei flüge mit über licht tempo genauer zu erforschen und
vielleicht bald sogar zur realität zu machen ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle spannenden facts dazu
Ist der warp antrieb physikalisch gesehen
Realistisch und wie weit ist die forschung, zu diesem thema herzlich willkommen bei pixum science fiction
Ja und wir bei whatsapp dabei sein könnte das erfahrt, am ende. Des videos die klassische. Physik und noch, konkreter einsteins relativitätstheorie
erlaubt die idee eines antriebs mit überlichtgeschwindigkeit
einfach nicht so viel steht fest noch die regel nichts ist schneller als lichtgeschwindigkeit
gilt für eine sache nicht nämlich für die raumzeit selbst also die grund matrix
Des universums sie gibt es diese obergrenze nicht und das bedeutet ein wolf antrieb wie in star trek könnte vielleicht doch
funktionieren denn das universum dehnt sich mit überlichtgeschwindigkeit
Aus bleiben wir also mal bei dem fiktiven beispiel eines raumschiffes denn durch den warp antrieb wird eine, lokale
verwerfung in der raumzeit erzeugt konkret bedeutet das dass die kosmische grund matrix vor dem schiff
Gestaucht und hinter ihm jedoch wieder gedehnt wird ein
Stern der also zunächst hinter dem schiff lag
Ist dann lichtjahre entfernten stern der dagegen weit vor dem schiff liegt der ist plötzlich in reichweite
Verantwortlich dafür ist die kompression der raumzeit mit dem raumschiff passiert dabei
Sehr wenig es bleibt zu seiner lokalen raumzeit matrix gesehen unbewegt und
Schwimmt quasi auf der welle der raumzeit mit das tolle daran die passagiere bekommt keine probleme mit g kräften und auch
einsteins gesetze bleiben unberührt stellt euch das mal vor wir könnten schneller als das licht sein das wäre wohl eine der größten entdeckungen
Überhaupt und nicht nur in science fiction filmen sondern auch in der realen forschungswelt gibt es theoretische überlegungen zum walk antrieb schon
1994 gab es dazu ein modell in dem der warp antrieb ein raumschiff zehnmal schneller als die lichtgeschwindigkeit
macht erdacht von dem mexikaner miguel
alcudia doch dafür notwendig ist eine
Lokale raumzeit verwerfung und das kostet eine unmenge an energie unfassbar viel so viel nämlich wie die masse des
Jupiters gespeichert hat um das zu umgehen
Könnte man den werbering allerdings in donath vom entwerfen und ihn in schwingung versetzen diese idee kam einige zeit später
von einem nasa physiker doch in zukunft ein weiteres
Denn man wusste nicht einmal wie man die raumzeit konkret denen und stauchen könnte in dem modell von
994 war von einem raumschiff mit exotischer materie die rede dass man mit negativer masse um geben müsse
Denn die würde dann gegen die gravitation angehen doch wie genau soll sich so eine negative
Masse wie soll die aussehen wie soll sie entstehen fragen auf die es bisher keine antworten gibt dazu kommt eine tolle reise
stünde uns dann nicht in aussicht denn in einem wort angetriebenen raumschiff wäre man komplett vom restlichen universum abgeschnitten eine
kommunikation mit dem
Draußen die wäre unmöglich so weit die theoretischen überlegungen aber es gibt auch schon experimente zum warp antrieb
Weltweit beispielsweise meinte vor einigen jahren in seinem experiment den realen wort effekt nachgewiesen zu haben den
Oszillierenden warp ring stellte er mit einem. Hochspannungs ring kondensator nach mit einem laser interferometer
Wollte er tatsächlich eine verformung der raumzeit registriert haben und zwar um 1 10 mio
Derselbe forscher war es auch der vor drei jahren den so genannten drive getestet. Hatte das steht für elektromagnetische
Und heißt eben so viel wie elektromagnetische
antrieb quasi eine art
elektromagnetisches capito mobile und auch hier weitwurf anzeichen entdeckt haben konkret bastelte sein team einen hohen metall kegel der einen
mikrowellenherd feld enthielt die mikrowellen photonen
Kollidierten mit dem metall warnt und erzeugung weise folge einen winzigen schub und verformten somit gleichzeitig auch irgend ein wenig die raumzeit doch
als andere forschungsteams das experiment wiederholten konnten seine messergebnisse nicht bestätigt werden zudem
Sprechen sie gegen alle bislang bekannten regeln der physik und so fasst die nasa die ganze
sache relativ nüchtern zusammen zitat science fiction autoren haben sich viele arten von
Interstellaren reisende vorgestellt aber schneller als das licht zu reisen ist derzeit einfach die magie näher der bordwand ried wird für die
absehbare zukunft weiterhin ein traum bleiben
Ja
Und falls es uns irgendwann doch einmal gelingen sollte würde das die ganze
wissenschaft auffüllen und neue theorien werden dringend notwendig denn dann würde unser komplett ist verständnis des universums
Kopf stehen und vielleicht passiert dann auch das was in star trek vorhergesagt wurde in dem moment in dem wir den warp antrieb
Erfinden nehmen außerirdische kontakt zu uns auf es bleibt also spannend
Wenn er als erstes neues zum thema warp antrieb und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
hierbei whatsapp und zur begrüßung gibt es ein kleines goodie einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genau mit der glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch. Draufklicken fast wie wolf antrieb antrieb ohne treibstoff ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran